foreign
held the call with zelinski weeks before
Tucker's uh was was fired basically
media Mogul Rupert bird are purportedly
held a call with Ukrainian president
zielinski this is the [__] head of
Fox News
in March just weeks before the ousting
of Fox News top critic of U.S support
for the country's war against Russia
Tucker Carlson details of that pierce
conversation remained sparse but they
did not they did not discuss Carlson
directly it remains unclear if the call
had anything to do with his firing
senior officials with the uh with the
country's government have however
repeatedly made their beef with
Carlson's coverage known in the past
zelinski also recently held the call
with Murdoch's son an Heir Apparent Fox
Corp CEO of Murdoch is his son murder
Lance Lanka Murdoch the outlet reported
uh so that's fine now I'm not saying
look here that's not the reason I don't
think that was the reason Tucker was
fired just let me be clear okay but what
I do think is let me pull up there but
what but what I do think is is that
that is one of the reasons I think that
Tucker was let go for not one reason for
several reasons and here's one of them
oh you told me about this yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so all these things are connected this
is a really weird like Pepe so so
here you go check this out
this is uh Tucker you know he does his
show from his from his Studio Tucker
Carlson today they'll show you this for
Fox Nation and this is before the
interview he had with uh Andrew Tate now
let me just tell you the uh the the
setup for this
um they're trying to get Andrew Tate on
to zoom in because he's in Romania
um he asked him how he should dress
Tucker's producer asked him to Tucker
asks tells his producer tell him to wear
a suit
um and now you have and now you have the
setup here you go I I don't want to be a
slave to Fox Nation which I don't think
that many people watch anyway
um we're gonna uh because I I you know
I'm like a representative of the
American Media now
speaking to an exile in Romania and
welcoming him back into the Brotherhood
of journalists
it'd help us out if he wore a sweater
because you asked him not to wear a suit
looks
he's a pissed is that okay
I I
mean this is airing on the nighttime
show and I wanted to look official I
don't want it to be like bro talk and I
and I I don't know what I mean
but nobody's gonna watch it on Fox
Nation nobody watches Fox Nation because
the site sucks so I'd really like to
just put the dump the whole thing on
YouTube
question
arrogant pieces [__] makes fun of the
streaming platform that they're on what
kind of like sociopathic a real a real a
real ungrateful piece a real Loose
Cannon is what I will call being a real
can in there Tucker and we would never
do anything not us we're Pros that's for
sure we are Pros over here
um but anyway that's just my view
um
uh I'm just frustrated with uh in it's
hard to use that site I don't know why
they're not fixing it it's driving me
insane oh sorry I'm playing a [__]
clip of merch from a couple weeks ago
and they're like making like Lifetime
movies but they don't they don't work on
the infrastructure of the site like what
he's calling out all those shitty movies
that they're making on Fox Nation it's
crazy and it drives me crazy good for
you man we're doing all this extra work
and no one can find it good for you
unbelievable good for you I don't know
who runs that site
yo the way his eyes popped open yeah
holy [__] yeah he's [__] pissed dude
and you don't I mean I don't for some
reason this feels like it gets closer to
home than anybody else anything else
going on I I just I don't think that
this was like a once in a while thing I
I think they've wanted to give her to
Target I think he's always been a pain
in the ass
because if you work for a place I mean
you see the [__] he says on the air
about his own workplace so you would
imagine he's probably a pain in the ass
off there when he's talking especially
he's talking to like Fox producers that
are trying to set good he's like no it's
[__] stupid and by the way the only
way this Media Matters about this by the
way so Fox right now is currently
leaking stuff to Media [__] matters
the Democrat organization Media Matters
because that's how mad they are so they
this is not helping you because first
off this isn't that juicy no it actually
somebody being mad at their job or their
boss is a normal thing that all of us if
anything like you're about to say right
more relatable yeah he's more relatable
he's more relatable because everybody is
felt that way and you're not by the way
yes Tucker has earned the right to be an
opinion I said that's the that's the
point we're saying Roman legion if
anybody's earned it it's the guy with
more [__] viewers than any other
cable news
[__] you know Rupert Murdoch's another
piece of [__] and in reality the the
only reason Fox Nation exists and was
being held up was because of Tucker
Carlson's documentaries name another
thing on there off the top of your head
can you no I have it what had it
no I can't think of anything else cops
reruns that's yeah
I know where the link to support is on
the page
[Music]
um
to what we're doing over there on season
today I know but we're doing our part
we're like working like animals to
produce all this content and the people
in charge of it whoever that guy's
whatever his name is like they're
ignoring the fact that the site doesn't
work and it's I think it's like a
betrayal of our efforts that's how I
feel so I of course I resent it
good for him man good I don't know how
this was
whoever's leaking your [__] sucks like I
hope sucker has been was filming all
kinds of [__] now too and he just starts
dropping everything he'll be like yeah I
yelled at them all the time this place
sucks can I find can I this this is not
this is an earlier interview he did but
can I drop a little nugget for you
something that I missed and I think we
both missed because we would have played
this on the show
Defender by conspiracy if you go on TV
tonight and say I think the Earth is
flat people just laugh at you they don't
care if you think the Earth is flat it's
not a threat to anyone
but if you say like what what actually
happened with building seven like that
is weird right
isn't that by the way can I just say oh
God okay can I just say that that is
that has always been our philosophy on
this show too when you wanna when you
want to explain like you don't need to
spurg out on people it's like like he's
like the way he phrased that was perfect
like what is brother that's weird right
like you don't you don't need to be like
some spurgs think they need to just
that's all you need all you have to do
into your [__] ear and it's like you
don't you just need to go wow so like
just a lone gunman and he had a terabyte
of porn on a Windows 98 computer and
removed a hurricane door and he had no
showcasings at his feet that's weird huh
that's a weird story and then you leave
it alone that's Marsh we're getting a
call from the ADL look at the sign it's
merge we're not no we're not gonna have
to give you twenty percent yeah
10 everything this is terrible
it doesn't like what is that right if
you were to say something like that on
television they'd flip out they would
flip out so you'd like lose your job
over that why why it's my country right
it's an attack on Mike tree can I ask
you like I don't really understand do
buildings actually collaborate no they
maybe they do I don't know
but like why can't I ask questions about
that Tucker unleash is gonna be real fun
to watch I think you think you're not
allowed to ask questions about
is something you should be asking more
questions about
how
many times have we said that we've said
that all the time and that guy was
[__] stone-faced until he said that
he's like okay that's funny it's a good
point how many times have we said that
how many [__] times uh Chuck Norris
Gun Club R.I.P Davey Croco thank you rip
Davey Croco is he truly The Joker
because he's always giggling I know and
he's always dropping insane like [__]
red pills
Tucker Carlson gets home at night and
wipes the the [__] Cover Girl off his
face and he's it's it's actually Joker
is white yeah underneath
all right and uh this is Megan Kelly
about the Tucker situation I wanted to
play as well who by the way I want to be
clear can still get it oh God yes she
looks a little rough sometimes when the
makeup people don't um for her age how's
Megan Kelly I'm in termination and um
have a lot of thoughts about it I wanna
I think break some news for you Tucker
Carlson hasn't actually been fired and
all this is true by the way check this
she's about to say makes sense he's
still an employee of the Fox News
Channel yes what happened was Suzanne
Scott called him she's the CEO on Monday
morning she has an Insider morning and
said
um see 54 she looks great 54. oh yeah
that's good that's good uh so by the way
I just want to point something out this
is another situation of like hey how did
you guys how did you guys know all the
stuff about Crowder training video well
sometimes you know people sometimes you
know people that know people and they
know people and they and they know
you'll [__] throw a grenade because
they don't a lot of other people yeah
some people aren't allowed to throw
grenades you know like because they know
like there's some people uh that they
can go and gossip about other people
with and they'll all keep it quiet but
when you want something to leak you need
guys like us that when you hand them a
grenade they pull the pin and throw it
before you even explain to them what it
is what's this dude wow what did
right
Scott called him she's the CEO on Monday
morning okay this is funny SK 37 she has
more replacement parts than a B-52
that's
that's good line and I will be stealing
it and said you've got 1992 Jeep alone
if
yeah but they put the sail cloth on it
and the big tires and the one on the
back that's why she tells everybody
she's [__] part Cherokee yeah [__]
Jeep Grand Cherokee
um he was not going to be allowed to do
any more shows and that he had been
kicked out of his company email
and now they're going to have to
negotiate and exit
um
well because he still has a contract me
uh suggests someone told me I wonder who
told you your friend Tucker one of the
few podcasts he's done has been yours
yeah is that she said it's going to be
an amicable parting
right isn't it
man you could tell she you'd always tell
when somebody knows she actually
probably knows the voice and she also
hates those people too of course
Scarface bursh uh five dollars Royce is
gonna need 10 of night wave radio
Revenue watch it [__] watch it
[__] are you gonna be much of that
much longer on YouTube I hear you I'm
completely catching Tucker off guard but
Tucker's not fired that's my information
that he still needs to negotiate the
exit and that means they have to pay him
until he negotiate this exit yeah of
course you can't just not pay him he's
getting paid he's paid vacation right
now
you know what he's on he's on paid leave
like a cop who just shot a black guy
dude he is just chilling and this in the
spring it's just getting nice now
yeah and he's on the gulf sides you know
the water's already probably nice and
warm I I did I went I went to the beach
this weekend and the water was awesome
well it was great just [__] chill out
I mean I went to the east and by the way
that was the East Coast beach too so
when that water's warm you know it's
warm golf's probably boiling he's not
free to launch a podcast or a digital
show or negotiate with other employers
at all because he's still under contract
they pulled a show off the air they also
fired his executive producer Justin
Wells and though he tried to find out
why they Justin Wells was one of the
dudes I know that was watching us for
the Waffle House Wendy thing so shout
out to Justin Wells shout outs I mean
he's probably watching this he's not
preparing for a show tonight Jesus
Christ no that's a good thing take your
time off but I like I love everybody
over there wouldn't tell him I don't
know him paid
man I'm an executive producer oh
executive producer Mike executive I I
might tell him why
I mean to me that's just so
disheartening he's been at the at the
company for years he'd been in the prime
time for
seven years and saw Fox News that scared
Hannity for one of the most difficult
times in its history the immediate era
Post Roger Ailes where they did Roger
hellsle if Megan would you not have any
idea Megan what did he do because he was
a pretty well-known guy do you know
anything about yeah go back a little
further just can we start this story a
little bit earlier start from the
beginning why would Rogers have to leave
I already quit like that it's weird you
know there's an HBO movie about it I
believe
I think it's called what ailsia
put that on Fox Nation yeah there you go
for your lifetime yeah next to your
[__] your your three-hour Jesus
documentary that no one watches right
they didn't know up from down they
really didn't have strong we had Alesia
is rated R it's [__] no and by the
way in France in France it's NC-17
there's the unrated version full anal
whoa nice no no is that what you think
Roger Rose is the one getting pegged oh
yeah it's not great by Hannity no no no
what will O'Reilly because it goes back
even further what was what was stroke
face woman's name oh God God I can't
believe I forgot her name we used to
make fun of her like all the time
management Lauren Ingram no stroke face
half it the one the restaurants don't
talk like that oh yeah I Tucker Carl
sometimes well somebody in the chat will
tell me I completely Nancy Grace no she
looked like Paula Poundstone
and they had lost two of their biggest
stars Bill O'Reilly and me
um calm down
before Tucker she was I mean you know
relatively speaking so Tucker takes over
it's a huge order you know that he was
given and he did it he smelled Greta Van
Susteren is pegging Roger thank you
thank you wow
we completely deleted that from our
brain she was so worth it sorry I had to
make room for more important people
seriously I could clear my brain cache
yeah exactly sorry I don't he took a lot
of risks and she wasn't hot enough that
was the honestly that was the problem he
was heterodox he was he pushed against
the Orthodoxy on so many different
things
and typically Fox News like that
so why why now what was it that led them
to treat their number one star with such
disdain I mean dripping disdain to the
point where he can no longer access his
email he doesn't get to tell his own
team he doesn't get to yeah that's right
they cut him off they cut off his email
and he didn't even get to be the person
to tell his producers and his team so
like they they didn't even I mean he
obviously had their phone numbers and he
told them but they were trying to cut
him off say goodbye
years ago
um when I was like the upper management
for that company they [__] literally
did the same thing I I got a call from
one of my guys being like hey man sorry
about that and I'm like sorry about what
like I was just I was literally with
sitting with my girlfriend on the couch
and I'm like sorry of what I mean he's
like I got fired blah blah blah and then
I started texting around everybody's
like oh yeah you're done oh I was like
oh cool man okay nobody told me
and unlike Don Lemon he hadn't been
[__] guys in the ass
immersed making out on the beach with
inverted colored dogs oh my god with
this man on page
and controversy after controversy inside
screaming at screaming at every 45 year
old woman at the whole foods for being
old and a woman
[__] hide the building against his own
colleagues yes the leftist media had
been coming after him repeatedly and in
the case of dominion to some extent
lawyers though he wasn't their primary
focus so what was it what would you yeah
so by the way that little that little
line you heard there
and again it doesn't matter you like man
Kelly or don't she if anybody I feel
knows she still knows people there that
would know this and I think my guess
would be Tucker one of The Producers
directly talking to her but
when she said there the Dominion thing
but that he wasn't one of the Prime
makes me feel that it without wasn't the
Dominion thing probably I mean because
he didn't go that hard on them no make
your own company turn against you like
that
the Fox News I know why they turned
against you bacon
because of the whole you know you know
you having a big mouth not big enough
not big enough for Roger rails they call
them Tunica nails
onions is clearly mad and I don't blame
them it'll be interesting to see what
the ratings were for the 8pm hour last
night Brian kill me hope oh I I actually
it's a couple days ago wait a minute he
did worse than Chris Hayes would have
done no no no no no no
are there updates please tell me what's
good
they replaced Tucker Carlson
with Brian Kiln oh no no no no it's a
rotating cast every night they have a
new like a different fill-in like so as
Brian kill me in one week and it's gonna
be like Tulsi gabbard and then will Kane
and so and then they still oh he's the
worst used Brian kill him he's the
[__] worst what are you thinking
I know what the problem is I know what
it is you ready they have a they have a
couple they have a couple Young Guns and
waiting right my opinion will Kane and
Bill malusion are the two like Young
Guns that they that they've been you
know don't forget about Petey Dukes okay
there you go so he's but he's the White
House guy he wants that job
that's the game that's the gig well you
want to leave that eventually but for
now you're like yeah White House boy but
I think they probably were like hey Bill
man you want to come and host he's like
nah I'm I don't want to be the guy that
goes after I don't want to be the guy
that goes up after Carlin you know what
I mean
good point I don't want to be there was
probably a lot of a lot of people like
I'm all right I had a podcast I gotta
look at that my kids recital
so they'll probably you want to let a
few bodies get through there before you
hop on you know really you don't want
the dirt is that buying kill me was the
[__] mopping up the [__] and the jerk
in the [__] jerk off move bro those
three like the people they're rotating
around is like it's almost like they
lost Tucker and now it's like when aw
tries to like pretend like Sammy Guevara
and jungle boy and Darby Allen are like
Main eventers and you're like they're
not they just don't have any Main Events
you have a pillar it's MJ after shut the
[__] up and then the main eventers
fought your other Main eventers in real
life and now everybody got sent home and
then your other main event is hurt and
needs to take a vacation yeah and your
other and by the way your other the
other pillars in Connecticut yeah yes
that's posted it uh it's a rotating cast
for now
and we'll see what they decide to do
there's not Brian's fault I mean here's
Brian FYI here he is uh in a moment oh
he is she doesn't like Brian so she
doesn't like Brian the way she just said
it's not Brian's fault but body language
is everything no I I'm I read it
differently than you but let's both
watch it and kill me hosted it uh it's a
rotating cast for now
and we'll see what they decide to do
there's not Brian's fault I mean here's
Brian FYI here he is uh in a moment
where he is kind of acknowledging what
happened I'll just play the 14 seconds
what can I say can I say something what
do you think I don't think she hates
Brian kill me I think she she likes
Brian kill me cringing
that's fair it's not his fault she's
like and then here is uh trying to
explain like I feel like it would be
like the way we I would feel if you were
stepping in for talking to me like look
we love Royce but Jesus Christ he's just
Tucker's time slot Let's uh see him
getting Tomatoes flung at him because
he's not Tucker like you said because
nobody's gonna be Tucker I might do a
Cody the first show be like so what do
you want to talk what do you want to
talk about oh God
hi everybody and welcome to Fox News
tonight I am Brian kill me as you
probably have heard Fox News and Tucker
Carlson have agreed to part ways I wish
Tucker the best I'm great friends with
Tucker and always will be does he feel
the same way
um
look this bugs me because like
I don't merchand I do this [__] all the
time the last thing that we [__] want
to do is be reading news and [__]
news all goddamn day it's in fact so so
honestly my my quick like rundown of the
important stuff that's happening was
driving on the way from the gym I'll put
Tucker on and kind of listen like oh
this was kind of going on and that's it
like that was that I ain't gonna now I'm
listening to [__] old music and 90s
rock and stuff because I'm like I'm not
about to listen to Brian Kelly tell me
Liberals are the real racist for an hour
[__] sorry
but right now it's time for Fox News
tonight so let's get started
uh kill me is a sweet guy see I know
okay you know what I'm giving merch the
point on this one that was the that but
but it feels like even though she feels
bad for him it feels like the way you
feel bad for a little brother like kind
of like oh kill me but that's what I
mean she's like ah poor Brian he's a
nice guy but she knows he sucks you know
what I mean it's like ah a poor guy and
he's a company man he's I'm sure
he wasn't thrilled to be asked to do
that
okay this is great particular day but he
did it he's a loyal employee and Fox
News is banking on its audience not
leaving it on its audience being more in
love with the Fox News brand than they
were 930 million dollar market cap gone
Tucker uh and we'll see we'll see
whether or not that's true but I just
think the way they handled it was
disrespectful and gross and I think
Tucker Carlson deserved better I
certainly hope that he uses Brian
Friedman my old lawyer uh shout out the
remainder of his contract The Wall
Street Journal oh Brian Friedman is very
Jewish don't you worry he's going to get
he going to get paid reporting that
Tucker was making around 20 million
dollars a year and that they will pay
him out on his deal you want a Betty
Pays His producers while he waits I
guarantee he pays his producers he's the
guy he's the kind of guy they'll do it I
don't know when it expired but he was in
the process
he could pay his producers for years and
weeks but Tucker said it himself like he
I listened to his book Ship of Fools by
the way highly [__] get the audio
version because uh he has he reads it
but he he openly he meets he goes I know
I come from money I know I do he goes
because what I'm doing is like I'm
telling you what they're doing like and
it was like very like man that makes
sense you know being a renewal so they
should pay him out and they should let
him out it was non-compete so we can go
out there and get his voice on the air
now when his audience will most be
missing it joining me now to discuss
both media shakeups the one at Fox the
one at CNN and by the way NBC Universe
Universal fired it's head head honcho as
well for an alleged affair with an
underling uh is the brilliant Victor
Davis hand I mean I like Victor Davis